The one at zero is stable, the next one is unstable, and the last one is stable again.
Why is that the case?
Assume that we are close to zero so that we have a small amount of fish
and this harvesting rate is going to quickly reduce that amount to zero again, which makes zero stable.
By the way, we can't approach zero from the other side.
There won't be any negative amount of fish. The second equilibrium is unstable.
Imagine that we had a little less fish that we would harvest more than we gain in this specific period,
which means we are going to further drive down the number.
We are moving away from that equilibrium.
Similarly if you have a little more fish then the growth rate exceeds the harvesting rate.
We are going to have even more fish.
In both directions, we are moving away from the equilibrium It's unstable.
And now the third equilibrium, if we have a little less fish,
the growth rate being curve exceeds the harvest rate, more growth than harvest.
We are going to end up with even more fish.
We're moving up on the horizontal axis towards the equilibrium.
If we have a little more fish, the harvest rate exceeds the growth rate.
We are fishing more than we gain, which curves down the amount.
So from both sides, we are going to approach this equilibrium, which makes it stable.
If we are in this region, we are definitely over fishing.
The amount of fish is going down all of the time towards zero.
The harvesting rate is way to large for the small amount of fish that we have in this region.